son Thompson goes inside and dunks it
and portland calls time foul here
there it is right Edward Allah against
Batum Thompson through the middle hit it
tough shop still 8.7 left back out to
Thompson miss Blake Thompson gonna go
[Applause]
playsuit advantage of DeMarcus Cousins
is a terrific half-court work
[Applause]
my life kisses patients here in the
Russia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we up top and we'll start a role here
tonight giving over the Thompson to the
baseline spins away from pressure
a tough shot they're hitting get behind
the backboard baseline nowhere to go
Jordan there comes back out pivots and
knocks down a very tough shot starts
behind the backboard that works his way
out just too much less than 20,000
people staring at you they're tired
three seconds Thompson over Danny Green
got it point three to go here whether
it's on the blocks whether it's a point
guard
whether it's Marc Gasol whether it's
Randolph klay Thompson
the way he just made that up on the go
on the way has to put more pressure on
draymond Green and drive the ball seven
straight points by goal of state and
there's Gordon misses and that's a good
step until it's equal it's not right
quick strike an elite back up to 20 epic
curry with 27 30 side help klay Thompson
has the right
[Applause]
Memphis oh yes it is Thompson reporters
in the second half he's been relatively
quiet yeah certainly is a feet way
behind the line the lateness got him
from behind and chance at four well when
you watch the klay Thompson is just as
he had in head all right doors for the
first time of season the Warriors didn't
reach 65 the initial defense was great
junior Smith trying to close hard
clearly thousand but what a shop so nice
to hurry
[Applause]
Thompson drives on Mozgov gets to the
random frozen checkout old presip dunk
from klay Thompson I don't understand
the switch morale in like you've been
doing to play on the end bounce just
another well as in bounce play where you
get someone turning ahead cuz to work
with you know it's not gonna leave them
at 2 at 1 play to end the quarter why
not 19 tops has got boat to you to see
drives around and let's simplify
that's a big show
without Steph is a mark to make the
Rockets r84 45 if you're not named James
Harden to play once the ball like
three-foot shots five of five in the
quarter he went at the career age 1013
and clay having a lot of fun
[Music]
Oh Thompson killing it from all angles
with that patient don't let the pretty
shot fool you less hard Thompson
green inside Livingston back out Barbosa
up top Thompson for three bucks a nerd
I'll tell you what Mike it's fun to play
bath Thompson way outside bang
Kristin Thompson time great shooters
come on Tristan Thompson you know the
rules
hand down man down too late of a
contestant
beautiful beautiful stroke play
Thompson's got it going and he sees the
basket mama call him clay nice lob to
clay and able to finish what a catch and
Lefty maneuver to get that in the bucket
[Applause]
play a deep three looking for the lead
they toxin three
[Music]
free-run 15 of 30 up Grima in the s-type
inside play another train
don't pollute their data to on ones with
the epithelium didn't used to take it
off
[Applause]
take it don't wash dish
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
curry finds Thompson four seconds west
nice feedback the taps it will banks it
in another gorgeous pass from David West
their Rancic curry curry fakes a couple
of dribbles gets inside out to Thompson
open three beautiful unselfish play
Durant to curry curry gets it to the
seams
hands it off on point pass to Thompson
and he does the rest quality quality
office by the Warriors even went that
he's able to have done I mean they're on
a pace to win you know high 46
incredible curry releases off the
turnover Oladipo nearly got back to
block it and points five assists and
three rebounds look shot blocked from
behind by Thompson
be their best options over five from
three
and he finally makes one there let them
open my mouth I'll tell you Ian sit by
the corner playing three
so we see curry clothes a bunch of
quarters clay said all right steps out
with the knee contusion
I'll close the third now the defense
should never let you kill the wall
[Music]
[Applause]
how much Marv in this corner has to
defense ignite at this Golden State team
in transition finding klay Thompson
Steph with a good look ahead Aldrich
shot clock winding down shot blocked by
Thompson knocked out of bounds Golden
State ball defensive plays late clock no
one to break him down off the dribble
great clothes out and contested by klay
Thompson
Thompson puffs and finishes his second
field goal of the final klay Thompson
drills the three point of the answer for
being just shot prior to this in
transition play Thompson moving
beautifully without the ball and adjust
his body to back at home produces good
things too cousins misfiring on the
three o'clock in one plays got to get it
off and he defense that is a big play
the lead assist man has a [ __ ] away
AGGA dollar with the steal
throws it up the klay Thompson throws it
down
beautiful people in a talent role right
now across the board as long as players
upset with every single call while they
realize that that's one of the things
were addressing quite toxic beautiful
shot that soft touch bounces off the rim
and rebounded by Zaza Pachulia I like
what they're doing it was a strong
double yes oh the bench is up everyone
is up a very nice strong move see that
you'd like to have seen four tents it
look this is a big game between two
teams that shot up a three-point play
instead I sure like the way that klay
Thompson is going to the basket tonight
we need to get him going to the
free-throw line
just biggest lead of the game here's
another look yes no questions
let's say
4930
to the Lord here's curry
[Applause]
hurry trip to the half-court
a little acid or it on the right there
glass brother this glass family
partnership
quickly to the trunk or
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is impressive that there's no
hobble Sue's game right now but when
that injury happened two on the shot
clock James has it deflected another
steal hurry ahead to dream on three
Edmond a slam and the Steel's igniting
the fast-break got an NBA player be the
star of equalizer to stay tuned after
the break it all series long in the
bizarre peculiar roles to this team this
year
well he's unproven as Thompson knocks it
in
and that he played very limited rings
book was also come on for the horse
Thompson's jump shot so smooth tonight
that's a big-time shot sort of Ward's
off Justin Jackson to create space let's
say would split it up and down yep got
pocket to very just shot
for might be really appropriate for NBA
history
[Applause]
class ready
beautiful steel input handling
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's not a shot that it came in
transition seven to shoot
they top sedate on college
shot
[Applause]
expect this from clay but he was closely
guarded by Jackson so we went by him
move into contact area but the officials
are letting the players decide who wins
what a play by klay Thompson the
presence of mind to stay with it and
shoot it without coming down I got a
dinner way final four seconds grandmas
deep kick-out to play this
the breasts have been assertive and
especially in the picnic oil situation
[Applause]
let's say that was a great defensive
possession for Utah Walker is crafting
skill block the runner was his left hand
he had to go a long way
[Applause]
you know the statue
and 94 feet later back door keeps on
going in by OKC it's right now down a 33
percent Georgia just 5 of 15 Thompson
with the slam just great movement
without the ball by Thompson no pressure
on the passer so an easy delivery by
Iguodala and late held on his curry and
Tucker on him shot clock at 5
rivers guarding to rent so tough green
top to the queen
Jerebko gets it pass inside initially he
wanted to get at the cook instead
Livingston nice ball movement here and
type to shoot Thompson has Turner on him
Thompson on the drive shot clock winding
down just gets it off in time and backs
it home
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content